صور مثل هذه تتحدث عن مجلدات
تسميها عرضًا للجاهزية العسكرية
من المقاتلات النفاثة إلى السفن القتالية البحرية
على الرغم من الوباء العالمي.
ينام على
أساس رادار
يكتشف الطائرة بدون طيار Hensolt هي
مجموعة إلكترونيات دفاعية مقرها في ميونخ وتعرض
نظامًا جديدًا لمكافحة الطائرات بدون
طيار لا يمكن أن يريح
كل دولة لضمان
سلامة
سكانها ولديها 80 بالمائة من المغتربين في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وهم يُظهرون مدى
اهتمامهم بالحفاظ على
السلام داخل المنطقة وخاصة
في الدولة
بموجب بروتوكولات اختبار صارمة
، شارك 900 عارض وآلاف المشاركين
في الحدث الذي يقام كل سنتين
ولسبب وجيه ، يمتلئ الشرق الأوسط
بقع اضطرابات
حملة قصف بقيادة السعودية على مدى ست سنوات في
اليمن
وهجمات الحوثيين بطائرات بدون طيار على
منشآت نفطية في المملكة العربية السعودية
استمرار التوترات مع إيران المنافسة الإقليمية والصراع الداخلي في ليبيا نتيجة استمرار النفقات العسكرية في هذه المنطقة بما يزيد عن مائة مليار دولار سنويًا ، وذلك على الرغم من حقيقة أننا شهدنا انهيارًا في أسعار النفط خلال ذروة جائحة تطمع 19 السعودية. تحتل العربية المرتبة الخامسة في العالم في الإنفاق الدفاعي كنسبة مئوية من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي ، وتنفق الإمارات العربية المتحدة أكثر من ضعف المتوسط الدولي ، ولا يشمل ذلك عقدًا بقيمة 23 مليار دولار لأسطول من مقاتلات لوكهيد مارتن من طراز F-35 النفاثة تم توقيعه في الأيام الأخيرة من إدارة ترامب ولكن تم تعليقها مؤقتًا من قبل الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن جيدًا ، فإن الأجهزة المادية هي التي عادةً ما تجذب الانتباه في برنامج مثل هذا ، على سبيل المثال ، تُعطى المباني المتساوية لمركبة روبوتية مسلحة للبرنامج لدعم درع إلكتروني دفاعي لحماية البنية التحتية الحيوية مثل خطوط الأنابيب والمصافي والموانئ هو وزير الطاقة والبنية التحتية في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة  تحدث عن المستقبل الآن ،
تحدث الهجمات عن بُعد في بعض الأحيان ويكون
التأثير كما لو كان ماديًا
للبنية التحتية التي رأيناها
تتم في أجزاء كثيرة حول العالم ،
يعطي هذا الحدث
مظهرًا ككرة مقاول مع عمالقة دفاع عالميين
يخدمون  كبار العملاء في
المنطقة ،
ولكن هناك أيضًا تحول استراتيجي
جاري بدأه الإمارات العربية المتحدة
طارق الحسيني هو الرئيس التنفيذي
لمجلس التوازن الاقتصادي في أبوظبي ،
وهو كيان حكومي
يدعم تطوير مجموعة كاملة من
تقنيات الدفاع
من الذكاء الاصطناعي إلى الأمن السيبراني
تريد دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة الحصول على المزيد من القدرات الأصلية ،
فهي تخلق توازنًا بين
الحلفاء عندما يمكنك مشاركة التكنولوجيا التي لا
تأخذها دائمًا
وتطلب التقنيات التي يمتلكها جيشنا
متطلبًا خاصًا فريدًا للغاية
لا يمكنك العثور عليه في السوق في بعض الأحيان ،
لذلك يتعين علينا تطوير منطقتنا التي تمتلكها
هذه المنطقة  عدد سكان صغير أقل
من 60 مليون
شخص يثقبهم فوق وزنه في د
الإنفاق على الدفاع الآن ، من المقرر أن تفعل الشيء نفسه
مع خبرتها العسكرية الخاصة
[موسيقى]
جون مراوغ سي إن إن أبو ظبي